i got to ask you about the hand tats i
remembered when i watched when you
watched the first goon movie you had
hand tats and i thought that was your
character and then you'd come on the
show over the years and i noticed like
you've got serious tattoos on your hands
i do it worked uh for the movie because
i'm playing this tough guy but um but i
also have some
bad tattoos right
bad ones so
tell us about the bad ones uh first of
all
are they visible to us right now but no
no those are fine no they're really
really embarrassing ones i mean i think
oh
do you have any bad tattoos
tell me everything
um
i
my first tattoo
there's probably like you know with how
i got named there was like zero thought
going into it my friends were like let's
get you a tattoo it's like my 18th
birthday
and it was like cool i guess yeah and uh
and they said you should get a lightning
bolt tattoo because you're fast
you're a fast runner i'm like yes
that's a great idea
and so i have a lightning bolt tattoo
this big
right here oh mike
on the side of your thigh but it's on
the outside that's good because if it
was on the inside it would be like your
junk is shooting a lightning bolt
your accent is so much better
look what i can do
you